It's okay for a man to sleep with X amount of women,
but when it comes to a woman,
and excuse me for using this term,
if she has a high body count,
then this is not something that is praiseworthy.
This movement now
glorifies and venerates a man sleeping around,
and he's considered masculine.
He's considered a man,
someone who's progressive,
someone who's doing well, right?
So it's okay for him to countlessly now
sleep with women, huh?
It's. It's okay for him,
but when it comes to women,
it is considered something, right?
This phrase.
Why is it okay for him and it's not okay for women?
We are not in need of these movements.
And that is simply because Islam is so perfect.
Who puts these laws down?
If it's the man,
there's always going to be. What? Contradiction?
But we have the divine law of Allah.